all right
all right all right i think we are
getting live
right now
and we are being redirected to youtube
so we should be live here right now eden
how are you doing
uh pretty good how are you i got no
complaints man
as people come in here we're going to uh
to quickly figure
out uh first just where they are uh
where they're coming from so if you're
starting to
get in here let us know in the comment
section where exactly you're tuning in
from
uh around the world as we do this live
stream we're gonna be talking about
decentralization we're gonna be talking
about bitcoin
all kinds of great stuff today uh and we
have one of the uh the world's experts
uh here with us with iago so uh in the
chat section go ahead and leave a
comment
in terms of where are you tuning in from
today
to watch this and i'll read some of them
out say hello to people before
we get started let's see who do we have
let's see let's see
takes a second for the comments
to load
all right so let's get started now we've
got about
a good number of people watching and uh
so maybe i go let's just get started
with your background
where exactly uh did you grow up how did
you get into technology when did you
discover bitcoin
uh and what kind of fascinated with you
i grew up in apartheid south africa uh
to
a family that had managed to survive
the hyperinflation of the weimar
republic
and then uh the holocaust by
basically um converting liquidating all
of their
earthly money into uh golden gems
and they went through all kinds of
remarkable stories and and terrible
suffering
and then when i was growing up in south
africa
many of them were members of the anc
which was the
it's basically nelson mandela's
eventually a
political party fighting for for freedom
in south africa
and because they were associated with
the anc they
uh were at some point declared
terrorists by the
south african government and so in the
middle of the night one night when i was
just a little kid um i was woken up by a
lot of commotion and i
kind of grabbed my pillow and walked out
to see what was happening and
my uncle had was kind of out of breath
and had just arrived
at our doorstep and my grandfather was
giving him the keys to the car
because he needed to switch cars so he
wouldn't be traceable
and he's he and his wife drove out
of south africa through the night to
[Music]
botswana uh
not long after i became a gold smuggler
because my mother
started buying krugerrands and sewing
them into my clothes and sending me a
loan overseas
because they wouldn't search little kids
in the unscots airport
and we needed to get money out of south
africa to our family
so uh sometimes i joke that i've been a
bitcoiner
uh for you know 30 years but um
explain the gold smuggling a little bit
more because that's a fascinating story
so
kind of walk through exactly what was
happening uh and what you were doing
yeah so so there were
a few things first of all you know uh
part of my family had
as i mentioned fled south africa as
political
um escapees basically um
and to get money to them uh wasn't
simple because at the time in south
africa there were very substantial
capital controls
but south africa produced 80 of the
world's gold at the time
and that's what south africa was famous
for and um the south african government
minted a gold coin called the krugerrand
which is one ounce of gold
and it traded at substantially more than
the value of one ounce of gold because
it was so rare because you couldn't get
them out of south africa
uh and so what my parents decided to do
was they bought a bunch of cougar ants
and then
um what they would do when is when it
was winter they would
sow these krugerrands into my winter
coat and then they would send
me overseas alone the reason they would
send me overseas alone is because when
you went through young spots airport as
a 9 or 11 year old kid
at the time uh you were basically
chaperoned but you weren't searched
and so i i i was the best conduit for
getting
funds out of the country at the time and
made
a few years later we we left south
africa as well and
and the first winter that i was living
in israel
uh the first day of winter i went to
school and i put my hands into my
pockets and i was like
uh-oh because i realized that i was at
school sitting on
a whole stash of krugerrands that we'd
forgotten to take out of a jacket
so um so i had to spend the whole day
at school being very careful not to lose
my my gold coins
um so yeah so you know
i come from a family that's always been
extremely politically active
um we have in one way or another being
on the bad side of totalitarian
governments from communists to the nazis
to the
apartheid government um across the 20th
century
and uh when i grew up i studied
neuroscience
uh and in particular neural networks and
i then immigrated to the united states
because i thought that the united states
was the country of freedom
of the country of free markets and i
wanted to be part of that
and i started a biotech company and
uh my focus was on neural networks and
using basically machine learning to try
and create better diagnostics
and so i was reading a lot of papers in
network science
and one of the papers that i came across
in in early 2011
i think it must have been around now
like february 2011
was the satoshi white paper and i
remember i had you know
freezing pittsburgh day february
and i had my coffee and i spilled my
coffee all over my laptop
because my mind was blown by that paper
a lot of people
you know have the story that they kind
of took a long time to warm up to to
bitcoin but i think because of my
background
i i was primed like i was into network
science i was into
i understood the value of having
sovereign money
and that afternoon i sent out an email
to everyone i knew saying this is
this is what you need to be getting into
now and i was ignored by basically
everyone but but it screwed up my life
because i've been i've been in it ever
since
so when after you set that email like
what was the first thing that you did
did you know that you wanted to go
and buy a bunch did you want to work on
it um kind of
what was the next couple of things that
you did well i was very poor at the time
because i had uh started the startup i
put all my money
into the startup um i had about 230
dollars in the bank
and i was still trying to figure out how
i can get bitcoin and i was trying to
figure out
how you wire 230 dollars to mount gox
without to like japan without
it costing you 230 in fees
um and eventually what i did is
i left my startup and i um
i moved to san francisco and i took a
job with a company called zynga which at
the time was the fastest growing game
company in the world
and the reason i wanted to work for
zingo is because i was sure the digital
assets are going to be the future
and no company knew how to mainstream
digital assets
better than than sing at the time our
primary customer
was midwestern housewife we had you know
hundreds of millions of customers around
the world
shortly after i joined and so i i was
with that company for
um several years all through the ipo
i helped uh turn
zinger into one of the first companies
in the world to accept bitcoin as a
means of payment
um and um
and then i i uh when i left zynga i
i helped set up an organization called
data uh to
try and work on the regulatory issues of
bitcoin
uh and then uh in 2013 i
i set up not one but two bitcoin
companies
uh one was bxil which was designed to
help uh
exchanges that were losing their bank
accounts process payments and the other
was more ambitious it was called
epiphyte and um
uh the goal with equifight was to uh
work with banks
to turn bitcoin into the global
settlement mechanism and replace swift
it's kind of like ripple without the
[ __ ] coin
and uh our customers included barclays
fairbank
bbva cba we had um
seven out of the ten largest banks in
the world as our customers uh
in 2014 2015 but they were
terrified by the uh like
the innovation departments loved it um
the actual board of directors
uh usually wouldn't approve it didn't
approve it ever
and so we we pivoted to using the
technology that we built
basically um turning fiat into bitcoin
in one place converting it into field in
a different place
or allowing basically almost
instantaneous transfers
to uh mechanism for getting remittance
to allowing remittance payments so we
were sending funds from europe
to um africa to latin america to east
asia
and then 2016 17 hit and we started
making
uh extraordinary profit
um we basically could go to our
customers and say we will do three
remittance for you
and we were buying bitcoin in uh europe
or
the uk and then sending it to thailand
brazil
zimbabwe and nigeria where it was
trading at a 5 10
15 25 percent premium and so we were
making on every single trunks for
sometimes 15 percent uh sometimes more
and uh and we were using our customers
funds as basically free float
so it was an extraordinarily profitable
business and that was part of the reason
why i got shut down
at the time we started doing our volumes
um
went up dramatically and the banking
partners that we had
uh one by one started shutting us down
uh and later we discovered that a lot of
it was pressure from
jp morgan at the time who were the
primary us
clearing bank for most of our banking
partners
so yeah yeah
i i after that i was i was done with
with the fiat world
i and i haven't been i haven't been in
faith ever since
all right before we get into what you're
building now i want to talk about the
importance of decentralization
especially around infrastructure so
uh everyone is very familiar if you're
familiar with bitcoin around
decentralized money i think it's pretty
clear as to why
uh there's significant advantage to
bitcoin being decentralized rather than
centralized
but one of the things that we've seen is
uh all of the infrastructure or most of
the infrastructure especially up until
recently
uh has been centralized around bitcoin
um there's a number of other places in
the market where there's been
decentralized infrastructure
or decentralized applications being
built but bitcoin specifically most of
it
uh that has been built in terms of the
exchanges the custody providers
uh the lending um you know platforms all
that has been centralized and so
maybe just kind of give us a quick high
level overview of like why do you
see the infrastructure and the
applications around bitcoin being so
important
uh as decentralized versions um and then
kind of how do you evaluate where we are
today outside of what you're building
right i think that's a great question um
you know
for me the the magic of bitcoin yeah i i
didn't get into bitcoin because i wanted
to get wealthy i got into bitcoin
because i wanted
to improve the world uh specifically i
thought it was important for people
not to be um
enslaved to a financial system
where they they were out of control
right bank could confiscate their funds
the government could confiscate their
funds
their friends can be censored uh and you
know part of this is
due to the experiences that i'd
experience um
and so the magic for me about bitcoin is
that it
is this revolution in creating
liberty a sovereign monetary system
available to everyone in the world but
it's dressed up as a get-rich-quick
scheme so
it gets adoption and um
the frustrating thing throughout the
years and i think this is
uh you know i think back to the
conversations i was having
in uh you know pre let's call it 2015.
with bitcoiners everyone was sure that
we were going to
have decentralized exchanges
decentralized lending
uh basically all of the financial
services around bitcoin would be
decentralized and the reason was obvious
you have this amazing decentralized
permission this uncensored uncensorable
monetary asset and um
if you then you know have to use it
through a centralized service you give
up all of those properties
so the exchanges get hacked the
exchanges require kyc
the exchanges become regulated um
and and and bitcoin loses the
very properties that you that that it
has that made people wanted in the first
place
what i think happened over time is
people discovered that it's it's
difficult to decentralize
uh bitcoin in a responsible way
um it was easier to start building
um decentralized projects on
ethereum and other services and then
over the last few years we've seen the
explosion of d5
now defy has
uh sort of the ponzinomics part of it
right where
people are just kind of looking for 200
percent apy
yield and creating token upon token upon
token and that's sort of the noise
but the fundamental value it provides is
phenomenal
the fundamental value of decentralized
finance
is the ability to retain your control
over your keys
for your asset even as you begin to lend
transact
and create a new financial system um
and so uh
i think the thing that we need to give
credit to ethereum for
is reawakening the interest
among bitcoiners in creating this
decentralized finance giving us the
feeling that
it um it is now within our cross and
um in conversations that i started
having
earlier last year and particularly often
pandemic hit
more and more people who i'd known in
this you know in the bitcoin space
for years started talking about their
frustration that there wasn't d5 for
bitcoin
and um and
yeah i think to me having decentralized
special applications for bitcoin
is a necessary step in
all of the things that imagine bitcoin
being able to achieve
that hyper recognization means you're
going to have to have a financial system
based on bitcoin the way you do that is
by having a decentralized financial
system
uh retaining your control over your keys
can only be done
in a decentralized financial system and
having permissionless innovation in
finance can only be done
in a decentralized financial system so i
think if we want to see bitcoin achieve
its full potential
it has to have a cloud of decentralized
financial services around it
so before we go any further in terms of
that decentralized infrastructure
the term uh permissionless innovation
i think is one that doesn't get
evaluated enough or discussed
talk a little bit more about like what
does permissionless innovation mean
and why is that important
yeah so i think um you know
almost everyone's seen the charts where
um the cost of education has just gone
up and up and up the cost of housing is
just gonna
happen the cost of healthcare is just
gonna open up a lot but at the same time
the custom computers have gone down
the cost of services that are provided
digitally has gone down google is free
facebook is free
why why why why that weird bifurcation
and i think the reason is that
industries have permissionless
innovation in other words
anyone can become a competitor anyone
can challenge the incumbents
and some industries are so protected by
regulation
uh that entry into those industries is
impossible the incumbents
never need to change because nobody can
compete with them and as a result
they become more expensive and worse
year after year
the worst example of this is the
financial system right
uh the big banks the large financial
institutions have hardly had to compete
uh at all uh and they've
hardly you know we still have bank
branches because
they've felt the need to to to figure
out how to provide us with a fully
digital experience and most recently
with the whole wall streets vet saga uh
we saw that when somebody actually does
create a model which may compete with it
right it allows people to
you know uh try something
like shorting uh uh you know squeezing
the hedge funds
the regulators in concert with the large
financial institutions can basically
uh turn it off so the reason that
permission is innovation is so important
is because without permissions
innovation you actually don't have
competition
and and the reason permission debate in
finance is so important is because
facebook is cool right like talking to
friends is very important
searching for information is very
important but at the end of the day we
all spend eight to ten hours
every single day working for money we
all
purchase the things that we want with
money we all manage the security of our
futures and our family's futures with
our finances
we basically express
ourselves and our deepest desires and
needs
in the way that we manage our finances
more than any other thing that we do
and so if there's one place that we need
to be free
one place that if we're not free they
can really squeeze us it's our finances
and that's why permissionless innovation
in finance is
probably more important than any other
single field
so today decentralized infrastructure is
basically
uh there's two schools of thought one is
that we are going to take bitcoin which
is decentralized money
and we are going to bring it into uh the
ethereum
or other smart contract platforms uh
there's things like wrapped bitcoin
um and many variations of that the other
is that we're going to build
new decentralized infrastructure on
bitcoin and around
bitcoin uh not including those smart
contract platforms
how do you break down that framework um
how do you evaluate what is most likely
to work
and then we can after we go through that
get into exactly what you're building
but just walk us through kind of
philosophically or theoretically how
those two different worlds
um is it a zero-sum game one wins one
doesn't is it uh coexistence
how do you view this yeah i i think
maybe i'll start with the end whether or
not it's a zero-sum game i
i think that's a very uh dangerous
approach for us to take because it
creates a
tribalism that we've seen and the reason
that the tribalism or sort of the
uh versus ethereum versus bch versus
ripple
right we're all enemies i the reason
that bothers me so much
is because i think what we're trying to
accomplish is extremely built and
extremely ambitious we're trying to
to take on all of the governments of the
world and
replace uh uh you know these fiat
currencies
with a sovereign currency where
we people are in control right so
probably all of the established powers
of the world are
raised us and i think it's going to take
all of
our concerted efforts
to be able to achieve our goal
so i don't want to create situations i
don't think it's good that we create
situations where there's
an opportunity for divide and conquer
among us
um that said i think
for us to come together we should come
together around one monetary asset and i
think that monetary asset
needs to be the one which has the best
chance of becoming the new
currency the new reserve currency of the
world and i think that's unquestionably
so uh i
i think we you know i think ultimately
this entire industry
is it moves with bitcoin right
we talk about the price of d5 going up
and then people have all kinds of
theories about why e5 is going up or why
the price of ethereum's going up or
whatever right
but we know why they're growing up
because the price of bitcoin is going up
it's the center of gravity and if it
goes down everything else will go down
as well
so now
to the to the first part of your
question right so okay so where do we
believe
we do build it on ethereum
uh do we try and build it on other
systems
um i think that you look at what's
happening
with d5 for bitcoin which to my mind is
the most important type of d5 right
because because
bitcoin is the most important asset uh
d5 for bitcoin hardly exists or maybe
doesn't exist at all on ethereum
the vast majority of bitcoin on ethereum
is
wrecked bitcoin which is basically you
go to a company called bitcoin bitgo
you give them your coins you lose
control over those points and then they
give you a token representing coins that
sit
in their vault so maybe you can use d5
systems
but you can't use d5
so if we want to build d5 for bitcoin it
has
built in in a bitcoin native way it has
to be built on the
ecosystem secured by the bitcoin miners
and the the the way that you use this
bitcoin should be
as trustless as possible and for that i
think we need to use bitcoin layer 2
solutions
uh and that's why i got some interested
in sovereign which is a form of c5 being
built on bitcoin later too
so let's talk about sovereign maybe we
could start with just kind of the
impetus of the creation
and the original idea uh and then kind
of what your involvement with the uh
with the project is
right so um yeah
as i as i mentioned you know especially
when covert hit
a bunch of um bitcoiners started getting
together and talking sort of online
things kind of slowed down there was
more time for conversation and there was
also
a need to come together one of the
things that
one of the initiatives that i was
involved in was an initiative called
block 19 and the idea was to try and get
mosques
to people around the world who didn't
have them and we were going to take
bitcoin and we took bitcoin donations to
make it happen
um and
uh because we're taking the donations
bitcoin
we wanted to build this in a way which
was going to be bitcoin native
and as a result we we built part of the
system
on a bitcoin sidechain called rootstock
and while this was happening we were
having conversations about all the
things that we had experienced and sort
of talking about where
things went and how what we were
surprised about and sort of how things
had played out in
ways which were different from what we
hoped or anticipated and it kept coming
we kept coming back
was that there was no decentralized
financial system being built
and at some point we just decided
all right screw it we're going to have
to do it ourselves
and so around june of last year we
started working
on uh trying to see how far we could
take the rootstock system
which is a system which has smart
contracts but it's merged mind with the
point
and and so it extends the capabilities
of bitcoin into the smart contract
in space and then when it sort of like
gives gives bickering the capabilities
of ethereum
explain that process real real quick
explain merge mining for those that
don't understand it in terms of
how you're taking these smart contract
capabilities and uh
essentially uh combining it with bitcoin
sure so um merge mining is basically a
weight of
of piggybacking on the bitcoin networks
security right so you get all of these
bitcoin miners and they're
they're in a constant race to look for
the correct hash for the next block
right
while they're doing this they're
generating millions
of other candidate hashtags which are
the incorrect cash
but if uh
but so so what you do is you create the
system
where it will allow you to be looking
for
the bitcoin hash and at the same time
that you're generating those hashes you
could
it could turn out that one of the other
hatches is sort of like lottery ticket
for a block to a separate chain and so
you have the ability to create a
separate check
which has different properties in this
case it has smart contract
properties that has an evm or the the
ethereum virtual machine allowing you to
create ethereum like smart contract
but it is mined by bitcoin miners and
basically shares the same hash power as
bitcoin
and one of the cool things about that is
that
not only does the chain inherit the
security
properties of it but bitcoin miners
inherits the additional um revenue
that the new chain provides you
basically are adding to the dirty bunch
of bitcoin
got it and so talk through a little bit
in terms of um
how sovereign is specifically leveraging
this idea of merge mining and the smart
contract capabilities
right so stubborn is built
uh to be merged mind in this way
and to have smart contracts which
basically allow you
to have a system which provides you with
the same functionality that you
would expect with the regular exchange
but
in such a way that you never have to
give up control of your keys you
transact
directly from your wallet and the system
is
uncertain so there's no kytc there's no
one who can even
try to kycu there's uh
no uh a way for people to shut down
the system there's no one who can
confiscate your funds
and so what sovereign has now after
several months of development
is it has the ability for you to trade
so for example to trade against stable
coins like usb stable points it has the
ability for you
to um convert uh bitcoin into a
bitcoin-backed stablecoin so you can
you can hold on to your bitcoin but get
liquidity in dollars so you don't have
to sell
apprentice spending dollars it has the
ability
to have um leveraged trading currently
up to
about up to 5x leverage so that's going
to
increase and it has which is probably
the most exciting thing the ability to
borrow and lend in defense for example i
land out my bitcoin in a way which is
trustless i'm not
i don't have to go to a centralized
service and i'm earning extra money on
my bitcoin so i i
went to work um and
the the original goal of sovereign
uh the original ambition was to to
basically do that provide
a service which is like an exchange and
provides lending and trading services
which
but in an alternative environment we
don't have to give up your control
uh what we were anticipating was how
much excitement
we were we thought that maybe no one had
built this because nobody
cared uh and it would end up being a
niche product for people like us
what we didn't anticipate was how many
people would care how
how many people would be like yes this
is what i've been waiting for how many
people shared our experience and so
we've seen the community of developers
grow
very very quickly we now have over 40
developers uh contributing to writing
auditing code documenting code
a community of several thousand uh users
uh we have people we have artists
writing comics about the thing we have
um people uh uh creating documents and
videos and just trying to spread the
word in every way they can
and as the community has grown so have
its ambitions
and people are now talking about
bringing children into the open source
operating system
of finance for the future there's and
you know one of the things that i think
i've heard you say
um is a decentralized version of
anything will be
larger than the centralized version
right today we have
you know different banks in different
countries because they can't be global
because the regulations are sort of
fixed to different countries and
and on the other hand we have facebook
google which are global and basically
dominate their space they become
operating systems for search
or for for social right so
imagine you had a borderless financial
system
right which was able to do everything
mortgages pensions
uh uh creating stable like fiat in the
form of bitcoin bank stable coins
trading lending everything right
but it was borderless it was
permissionless anyone could use it and
it could be anywhere
uh the more and more of the community
are now talking about well i mean
this is what we could build we can build
the next layer of bitcoin
take the the the asset which recreated
the monetary system and recreate the
financial system
in the same way so when you think
through this um
there's a whole bunch to unpack here
right let's start first with the
non-bitcoin decentralized world is this
something where you say
uh right ideas interesting execution
not valuable and sustainable over the
long term is this something where you
say right ideas
uh good execution uh will coexist
like how do you just view i guess
everything that's not being built on
bitcoin today uh over maybe a 10-year
period so the short term
ignore that just over a longer time
horizon kind of what do you think
happens there
i think for me i've gone through a bit
of a journey i started out extremely
skeptical of
ethereum i didn't think it would scale i
didn't think it would be secure
um i didn't think it would and
it might be i was right right like
bitcoin like ethereum today
maybe has the most hyper-inclusive
culture of
blockchain tribe but from a practical
perspective it's become hyper exclusive
like only very wealthy people can afford
to transact when the transaction fees
for like a traded 200 300
um but at the same time i was wrong
about so many things
the system has proven to be robust and
secure it's lasted now you know
it was for seven years uh more and more
sophisticated things have been built
and really remarkable tools have been
invented
the first uh uh truly permissionless
you know the closest we got so far to a
permissionless
competitive the federal reserve was
maker that which created
a ethereum backed stable coin compound
has created a decentralized money market
uni swap has
become the first decentralized exchange
to
beat even the biggest centralized
exchanges in terms of volume
i think these are not just sustainable i
think they're real
important innovations and and i've kind
of
come to realize that if we want bitcoin
to succeed
we can't ignore these things we have to
be curious about them in fact
nobody should be more curious about
these things than bitcoins
uh nobody should be uh more excited
and and and and more interested in
developing decentralized
financial systems than bitcoiners and
and
i'm sometimes disappointed that
part of the bitcoin community sort of
the kind that would you
may be called bitcoin maximalists have
have become a little bit narrow-minded
to too close-minded for for bitcoin's
own good
uh in not exploring this space more and
not
realizing that there is a huge
opportunity here
there used to be you know there are a
bunch of important means in the bitcoin
world
one of those means your points another
is horrible
right another meme is uh short the
bankers
right there used to be
a really important meet which is as
important as any of those
uh which was uh anything any technology
that improves upon bitcoin will simply
be adopted by bitcoin
we just don't hear that anymore and i
kind of want to bring that back
because i think it's a very very
important idea that
because bitcoin is digital money we can
build
on top of it we don't have to change the
base there we can build on top of it in
layer two layer three
and anything which is useful to bitcoin
can and should be adopted by bitcoin
and so when you think through this um
let's walk through some of the products
that you have
at sovereign so the exchange is a great
example i am with you that it's nearly
impossible
uh to ignore some of the innovations
that are happening just from a size and
market adoption standpoint right i
am very fond of saying my opinion
doesn't matter neither does anybody
else's like the market is the referee
um and so when you think of your
exchange walk
through what is the difference between
let's say uh the sovereign exchange
versus uniswap versus a coin base right
so kind of a centralized version
then you've got two different
decentralized exchanges
so how do those three differ from each
other
so i think the easiest one to
differentiate with is coinbase right so
coinbase i think is really important
role to play it's sort of like the
entryway i think if
you know you could think of being a
bitcoiner as a sort of like
steps that you take towards your
sovereignty right you start out you
don't know anything you dismiss bitcoin
you're a no pointer then you become a
little bit curious you're kind of
bi-curious right then uh then
you buy your first bitcoin and you keep
it you keep it on coinbase
and so you bitcoin but you don't really
own bitcoin
and then you become more self-sovereign
because you withdraw from the exchange
put onto your hardware or whatever right
i think the stage after that is that you
no longer need to use the exchange in
centralized exchange you can use a
decentralized alternative
so it requires a higher level of
sophistication but it provides you with
much more control much more
um sort of sovereignty for yourself
so that's how both uni swap and
sovereign are different
from coinbase now the difference between
coinbase
uh sorry between uni swap and sovereign
there are two obvious ones to my mind
one is uh
unity is built on ethereum and
um ethereum is competing with bitcoin on
features
right it's competing because it's got
the smart contracts it's competing
because
uh you know they they try to introduce
more technological innovations all the
time like proof of stake they want to
introduce
i don't think that you can compete with
a global reserve currency on features
right that that's the wrong way to view
it it's not a technology it's a
it's a special consensus um and
and the and i think that the technology
the specific features that you want
can be implemented on any chain
including
effectively through merge mining on
bitcoin
so that's one difference right i don't
think that i think ethereum
has provided an opportunity for
massive community growth it's brought
huge numbers of people into the crypto
ecosystem and it's
created new important and exciting tools
i just uh think that um
that needs to integrate much more deeply
with bitcoin if we want to have a shared
mission across the
entire crypto community the other
difference is that uni swap
is designed as a single purpose product
right it does swaps
and the theory in
the ethereum ecosystem is that you're
building these
legos right you're building you know
compound is the money market uni swap is
the
is the swaps uh uh fulcrum is the
leverage trading et cetera et cetera et
cetera
the and that's a very compelling idea
because it seems extremely decentralized
and i think it actually makes
a lot of sense under some circumstances
but there's a problem with
and the problem is that you can't build
everything on
air one uh ethereum is proving that with
the
extremely high fees there's no way to
build a layer one which is going to
scale
uh enough and so what you end up doing
is you
you need to have a sort of fractal
system where you keep on rolling up
uh you know you have you take things off
chain like with lightning or you
or like with us that roll up and then
you like hash them together and put them
back
ultimately to the the core blockchain
if you're doing that you need to have
something which is far more vertically
integrated
because until our technology improves
quite a lot and this will take several
years
the easy interoperability between
different systems which are not on the
same layer 1
just doesn't exist it's not there and
right now the ethereum ecosystem is
fracturing
uh people are going up into what you
know these roll-ups or these side chains
and ethereum semantic optimism arbitrary
these are all uh tools which different
depths are migrating to because the
fees on ethereum layer 1 have become too
high to work with
and that's breaking the composability
which allows you to use these different
lego blocks together
and so what we've done with sovereign is
we've built a system which provides you
with effectively a vertical integration
kind of like the
the the the mac or the apple of of d5
right it just works
but the lending just works with the
trading just works with the swaps etc
and the other advantage that this has is
that now you don't need to do
liquidity mining and a different token
for every single service
and start creating this this ecosystem
of never ending sort of
token upon token upon token upon token
whose value sort of becomes this
ponzinomic scheme
when you think through um kind of ten
years from now
right so kind of the future product
suite of sovereign um and the
decentralized infrastructure around
bitcoin
is this something where we can maybe
sharp shoot
and improve on certain financial
applications or is this a complete
rebuilding of the system where
literally financial institutions in the
legacy world will have to
embrace and start to play in this world
or they literally will be disrupted left
behind
like is this an alternative system and
the legacy system persists
uh or is this full-on disruption where
uh
if you do not embrace the new system
then uh you basically are rendered
uh valueless i mean
the other day someone asked me someone
was a
government organization but they asked
me to send them a fax
so old technologies never quite
die just like uh [ __ ] coin chains never
quite die right
um i don't think we're going to see the
financial system that we're familiar
with
completely disappear i don't think we're
going to see fiat currencies completely
disappear
but i think they're going to have to
learn to adapt to an environment where
they're no longer
the center of gravity and
um and i think that what happens when
you introduce permissionless innovation
into any industry
is that uh it starts off slowly
and then you hit an inflection point and
suddenly everything changes
right suddenly retail disappears
suddenly uh uh you know
um television like no
people don't have like television
antennas anymore they have netflix and
it happens like very very quickly
uh blockbuster goes bankrupt quickly
right
so what i think we're going to do
um what i think we're seeing happen now
is that bitcoin
is reconfiguring the way
currency works the way central banks
work they're all now
trying to figure out how do they get in
how do they create their central bank
digital currencies right
and i think what's going to happen next
is as we introduce that same kind of
permissions innovation into finance
we're going to see
at the beginning nothing and then
suddenly all of the banks all of the
financial institutions all of the
insurance companies will have to
scramble to figure out how they now fit
into a new ecosystem
which which doesn't look anything like
the ecosystem that they
effectively created when you think
through that world
talk a little bit about synthetic assets
and kind of their importance
uh in the ecosystem uh is that something
that
is sustainable uh kind of how you see
that uh synthetic asset
uh vertical playing out right i think
you know there are two
roles for synthetic accents one is to
act as sort of like a derivative
so let's say you want to take a long
position i know
oil or a breakdown it doesn't matter um
you can create a a token or
representation of you know
which which goes up with 2x
and down 2x the volume of bitcoin that's
a derivative right
um the second type of synthetic is there
are a huge number of vests the vast
majority of asks today are not
represented
uh sort of natively on any blockchain
and so people who want to trade tesla
shares you can't trade tests you have to
you know
and you don't want to do it on the
nasdaq you want to do it on ftx so you
want to do it on a decentralized
exchange you need a synthetic
representation of tesla shares
so i think the first form right the
these derivatives they're always going
to be there they're sustainable
these synthetic versions i suspected
over time
just because it's the most secure most
public most available way of
representing
any type of financial asset what we're
going to see is we're going to
ultimately see all types of equity all
types of bonds that instruments will all
migrate to be
natively uh blockchain
you know represented in the blockchain
there's folks who are asking and for
those who are watching live
go ahead and if you leave comments in
the chat i'm monitoring them and i'm
trying to weave some of those questions
in here
uh there's folks asking on the lending
side how do the rates
on something that is decentralized like
sovereign compared to the centralized uh
kind of peers or is it high or lower the
same how does that work
right truth is we don't quite know yet
because the
volumes on sovereign right now are quite
limited um
due to our strong emphasis on security
so we've been live since september but
we're only slowly
adding the ability for more people to
join and for
larger and larger transaction sizes so
right now
the amount being earned by people
lending out bitcoin is quite low i think
it's about 2.3 percent
um what we expect will happen is that as
it uh opens up and basically
you know the the barriers to entry are
diminished it will probably start
migrating towards being
the same marketplace as any other um
uh venue with one difference so if you
look at like the big players
in the bitcoin landing space today i
think you know you're looking at block
fight looking at nato you're looking at
celsius there's one thing that they can
do
to sort of juice their rates which
sovereign will never be able to do
so some of the biggest borrowers on
block fire or nexo or celsius
are um institutional borrowers who are
borrowing for
carry trade or market making or
arbitrage
what they do is they borrow without
putting down collateral
or putting down relatively small amounts
of collateral in other words
they come to celsius or they come to
block fight as
a financial institution and they say
look we have a credit score we have a
reputation right
so lend us the bitcoin and we will pay
you back whereas
in a decentralized system you can't do
that you have to have
you can't have fractional reserve right
because that is basically a fractional
reserve system
you can't have fractional reserve in a
decentralized blockchain based system
and so it may be that the centralized
services will always have somewhats
i mean it will be arbitrarily but they
may always have some
what higher rates that they can pay
lenders
um and i i think of that sort of amount
that we may be foregoing and sort of the
price of freedom and i think it's
something that we paid there's questions
about the oracle
problem uh specifically kind of third
party versus first party
how do you see oracle's playing into
this uh how important are they
in any thoughts on first first third
party
yeah so with sovereign we use articles
and we use articles to
get exogenous prices into the system in
other words the prices that are
happening in the rest of the world
so that um prices reflected in sovereign
are more
more robust um
you any any sort of
central point in in a system is a
potential
vector of attack or weakness and oracles
can potentially be centralized
so the decision that we made was to have
multiple decentralized oracle systems
feeding us information all the time and
what we
what what the sovereign system does is
it it takes this information from
the money and chain articles from the uh
chain link articles and it compares them
and if
there's a divergence in these prices it
um it can halt trading automatically in
other words the protocol itself
can pause trading until the price is
realigned
so it's not a perfect system because
you're still relying on on other parties
and third parties to provide information
and because the system can
end up being halted so far we haven't
had that happen
um but it is quite a robust system
because
um there really is no central provider
of data to the system anyone
permissions they can come and start
acting as a provider of
of data to the system without prices or
anything else
got it what's the part that is the most
difficult do you think as you build kind
of more decentralized infrastructure on
bitcoin is there one
specific product or one part of what we
consider traditional financial products
that you think is more difficult than
everything else
yes there's one non-traditional product
that is very difficult
and is at the center of everything and
where we put a lot of concentration
which is making sure that the
pig now is it when you're using your
bitcoin on the system
that it is that you can use it
trustlessly on the system because these
are not transactions that are occurring
on bitcoin main chain
you lock up your bitcoin on the main
chain and now you begin transacting on
it in a different shape
so having a truly trustless pig
uh is a technical challenge uh
which um uh
we're not 100 there yet so you are
you're not using you don't have the same
kind of security insurances that you
have with bitcoin
you have lower security insurances
uh and that's something which is being
improved on all the time
uh with regards to
the other question that you asked
there's also another really simple thing
that you can't do on a decentralized
exchange which is like simple everywhere
else but extremely exotic on d5 right
and that's just having a way for people
to take
cash directly you know like money in
your bank account or money you wanted to
use it on the exchange
they always need to find some kind of
gateway
right now um and so interestingly it's
like the basic things it's the simple
things
uh really on the on off ramps which are
the biggest challenges where we
we've been spending some like probably
most
before i dig into a bunch of these
questions that people have um
where can people go if they want to
learn more about sovereign if they want
to use their products
so the sovereign website is
sovereign.app spelled
s o v r y n dot app
um and um it's
you if you go into the library of dior
right
uh the library of do your own research
on the website uh
you can find a wealth of information you
can also try out
the system um so right now you need to
wait to get whitelisted to use the live
system but you can try it out on testnet
so test.sovereign.app
and if you just want to keep updated you
can you can follow
uh the sovereign community sort of like
a whole bunch of people are tweeting
through the same account
at sovereign btc
and so there's a bunch of questions uh
about
the token involved um everyone from
why do you need a token to will the
token eventually be traded on
centralized exchanges like finance and
how you feel about that
maybe just talk a little bit about the
token and kind of
uh you know what the logic and structure
of it is and then also kind of your
thoughts on how that will be
uh treated by the rest of the community
yeah so i think that the idea behind the
token is extremely simple
the token is not an altcoin it's not
trying to be a coin at all
uh the token which is uh
sov is designed to do something
extremely simple which was invented
hundreds of years ago it's basically
a way of coordinating the efforts of a
large number of people
by having them have the ability to vote
on the system and to earn the revenues
on the system
so in that way it's kind of like
decentralized
equity in a way right um
the difference is that you have to be an
active participant in order to earn the
revenue
in which you have to actually
participate in the governance
and it's not
uh that your claim on the on the system
is not
endorsed or protected by any court of
law anywhere
you know right if you if you buy shares
in tesla
tesla have to behave in a certain way
and pay you you know
if they're going to pay a dividend and
give you your right voter
right to vote because otherwise you can
sue them there's no one to sue
uh with sovereign but at the same time
you don't have to sue anyone because the
system is
governed um by the code with which it's
written
and and effectively is secured
by the bitcoin chain itself so it can't
it can't
do arbitrary things it can't it can't um
change its mind about how it's going to
treat you as a customer
so i see a bunch of people being
incredibly kind uh in the comments
young investor of a few others uh if
you're watching this live
go ahead and smash the thumbs up yes
that does help more people on youtube
watch it
and if you share it on twitter and tag
me or yago
we would greatly appreciate it uh one
other thing that um
i find really fascinating about all of
this
is um it appears that
decentralized financial system uh to
some degree
is having structural issues right from
just a
performance standpoint and central banks
and elected officials have to keep
stepping in and kind of intervening
but also there's a sentiment change and
that sentiment change is more
psychological than anything
we saw that with obviously the gamestop
and wall street bets
uh but there's been this kind of
underlying sentiment for for a number of
years now
how much of that is a tailwind for
what you're building and for bitcoin in
general versus do you think that these
technologies would be successful even if
that sentiment change wasn't occurring
that's a great question i i think that
these technologies would be valuable
regardless right i mean when i first got
interested in bitcoin i had no idea that
there would be a wall street space game
stop
anything right um
but what i did recognize was that
um we give governments a huge amount of
power we give them the monopoly over
violence
we give them a monopoly over creating
the currency that we use to to store
and represent all of the effort that we
put in in our work
um and and they have time and time again
acted irresponsibly with now
a lot of people i i maybe am sort of you
know lucky right so to speak
that i got to experience this firsthand
in a country that
felt like it was a developed country um
a lot of people who have grown up in
europe or in the united states they
they haven't experienced this in this
generation and so maybe they think it
can't happen in the united states or
you know in germany but um
not that long ago right in the 1936
the united states confiscated everyone's
gold
uh in in in 1936 germany was going
through hyperinflation
uh this is not a an unusual occurrence
it it is unusual to go through periods
where these things do not happen
uh where fiat is involved
so um to my mind
having an insurer a technology which
provides an
insurance policy against that was always
going to be valuable
and was and we would always at some
point reach
the point where um the
the the the game of just printing was
going to come to its
natural end and that it feels very much
like that's where we are now
unfortunately
in in the advanced economies of the
world because
that that's a dangerous time uh to be
alive and
and it's and it's really important that
we have
a solid alternative
i i tend to completely agree um
i'm going to uh to wrap us up here in a
second
but one other question that i've seen a
couple of people ask is just
in terms of how they can help right so
obviously using the product is one thing
if there's uh developers out there that
want to work with you but something
that's another but just maybe talk
through a little bit
um there's much people watching
especially people who watch this
afterwards
what can they do to help you and your
team be more successful
uh and continue to kind of push forward
the decentralized infrastructure around
bitcoin
right so sovereign is a community effort
and we have people
joining us in one way or another all the
time it's really easy if you're a
developer
especially if you have experience with
bitcoin or or smart contracts
um but even if you're if you're not a
developer uh
we we you know they're people who are
creating sovereign art you can see some
of it like behind me like these are
these are different people have created
different
sort of like superhero badgers and um
you can um uh test the system right we
have
we have we have an extremely
enthusiastic we don't have any people
who are
doing qa right we have a community that
we say look here's a new feature
go test it and a day later we have 100
complaints which is exactly what we want
right
um so you can test out the system you
can tell your friends and give them the
gift of sovereignty let them know
that it's now possible um
and and i think the easiest thing is to
just join our discord
uh you can find the link on the website
uh at sovereign.app
and um and and go into the bounty
channel go into the
the user feedback channel see what
people are talking about you can see the
devs talking about all of
the work they're doing in real time and
just jump in
i love it um before i let you go
uh any words of uh encouragement or any
thoughts on bitcoin in general in terms
of all of the uh the adoption the recent
news elon musk and tesla
uh michael saylor microstrategy just any
uh kind of things that are not sovereign
related but bitcoin related
i always knew this was going to happen
and i'm still shocked that it actually
is
i'm right there with you i uh
i said to somebody the other day it's uh
the two things that i know to be true
are one there's a foregone conclusion
that you myself and many others have in
our heads
uh but every milestone along the way is
just kind of if you take a step back and
breathe you're like oh my god uh
and then the second thing is that every
bit corner i know
wants the price to stay as low as
possible for as long as that is
it's so true every time the price goes
up i feel such pain
it uh uh i continue to tell people that
uh ultimately the price will not matter
right because things will just be priced
in satoshis and
and uh and bitcoin i think but uh on the
way up is exhilarating it is fun it is
this kind of adrenaline
but uh every bitcoiner kind of deep down
they
they do not want to see the price go up
in fact they want it to stay as low as
possible for as long as possible so i
think it's
yeah it's pretty funny that those two
things happen
cool yeah uh completely agree
listen it's been absolutely uh amazing
being on this
uh on this call with you and being able
to talk to you about these things
um check out some of them
all right listen guys thank you so much
for taking the time to do this i think
people will really
enjoy it and i'll do it again in the
future awesome
cheers